you know you start having thyroid
symptoms you go to the doctor
they give you a diagnosis you have a
hypothyroid problem okay then you're put
on
synthroid or some other medication
to give you hormones and then you ask
your doctor what is causing my
hypothyroid problem
and they might tell you
well your thyroid hormones are low
and you go okay all right you go back
home you start taking your thyroid
medication
and about a year later you're wondering
i don't really feel any difference my
energy is
still low i still am overweight
what's going on and then if you ask the
question what causes
a lowered amount of the thyroid hormones
you may get answers like well we don't
know it might be genetic there's still
research going on so it can be very very
frustrating because it's not about
correcting the thyroid it's about
managing your thyroid levels and if you
treat the thyroid with thyroid hormones
and you don't see improvements the
question is is that the real problem or
is that just the tip of the iceberg and
what i'm about to talk about is not
meant to replace medical care check with
your doctor before implementing any of
these suggestions
the only thing i'm trying to do is raise
some really important questions
if you really get to the root cause of a
problem then the problem results if you
don't and you keep managing the symptom
you're basically spinning the wheels and
potentially creating a future problem
because
one of the side effects of taking
thyroid hormones over a longer period of
time
is
you're causing your own thyroid
to not have to work anymore and you're
causing your thyroid to become
lazy and it reduces the thyroid's
ability to produce on its own so it
becomes very dependent on these thyroid
hormones and then the other question you
have to ask is okay what does the
thyroid produce it produces
t4 t3
as well as another hormone called
calcitonin right
are you ever given that hormone no
you're not one thing to me that's very
interesting about the thyroid is that
i think really and this is my own
opinion is that it's
a symptom of something else it's rarely
a primary cause there's so many other
parts of your body that can affect the
thyroid that are really ignored so i'm
gonna increase your awareness of these
other things that could be affecting the
thyroid one thing you need to know about
the thyroid is that t4 okay
the main hormone that the thyroid makes
is not the active form of thyroid
hormone it's kind of a
precursor to the active form which is t3
and the three and the four really
represent the number of iodine molecules
that are attached to this protein
hormone
so when the body strips off
one iodine it becomes active and 80
of this conversion happens through your
liver so if there's any problem with the
liver whether you have a fatty liver or
it's has cirrhosis or it has
inflammation that can affect the
conversions and so here you are treating
the thyroid and ignoring the liver that
could be one mistake the other 20 of the
conversions happen in the kidney so if
there's any problem with the kidney
especially if you are a diabetic or a
pre-diabetic or have insulin resistance
chances are you have a problem with the
kidney and that can affect the
conversion you also need selenium okay
for this conversion you also need zinc
for this conversion and there's two
other additional hormones that are very
very powerful
in not only blocking the conversion
but messing with the production of
thyroid hormones and that would be
number one
estrogen this is why you see so many
women start developing a thyroid problem
right after pregnancy both
hypothyroidism as well as hyper okay but
most cases of thyroid are an autoimmune
type problem where it's not really a
thyroid problem at all it's an
autoimmune it's an immune problem that
is developed after either a stress event
or
a spike in estrogen it just so happens
that estrogen does control or help
regulate the t cells and the other
hormone that i want to mention is this
cortisol
if cortisol is too high it basically
paralyzes the immune system and that
alone can set you up for an autoimmune
problem including hashimoto's which is
basically about 90 of all hypothyroid
type situations now since the great
majority like 90 percent of all
hypothyroid problems are really
hashimoto's
then we should also talk about the gut
because you have like 80 percent of your
immune system that starts in the gut so
if there's any type of
permeability issues in the gut like
leaky gut something like that certain
proteins can be leaked into
the tissue right beyond the colon
and create this whole immune problem and
you can start developing antibodies
against certain things there's a big
link between gluten okay gluten
sensitivity gluten intolerance an
allergy to the gluten and hypothyroid
problems especially hashimoto's a lot of
people when they get gluten out of the
diet all of a sudden get relief with the
hashimoto's so that's a really
important factor i wouldn't just go
gluten-free i would go
grain free completely so the other thing
involved with autoimmune diseases
especially hashimoto's is you always
have inflammation and the inflammation
is really what's creating all the
problem all the damage so if you could
just get rid of that inflammation
regardless of all the other things you
do
you would see dramatic improvement in
body function and one natural and very
powerful
substance you can take is vitamin d
vitamin d is not really even a vitamin
it's a hormone it acts like cortisol but
without the side effects you usually
have to take vitamin d in higher amounts
like 40 000 ius
to
get rid of the inflammation
part of this autoimmune problem as well
as selenium so those two things are
essential for an autoimmune situation in
general as well as hashimoto's a
hypothyroidic condition can occur in men
and women but it's eight times more
common women i really think because of
the estrogen component which i just
talked about estrogen regulates the t
cells and that can set a woman up for an
autoimmune
problem
also like i said before cortisol
paralyzes your t cells so
a really important question is when did
you start noticing
these thyroid symptoms was it after
a stress event or not to rule out this
cortisol situation let's just go through
the early signs
of hypothyroidism okay number one loss
of the eyebrows specifically the outer
part of your eyebrows okay number two
thinning of your hair
as well as dry hair all right the hair
just completely dries up and it starts
to thin and you start losing your hair
other than that you're perfectly fine
all right number three you start
developing a cold intolerance you don't
tolerate going into an ice bath for very
long okay you don't like the cold
especially in the winter but even in the
summer you have to always wear socks
number four your metabolism is so slow
no matter what you do it just will not
work
fast i would also focus on insulin
resistance okay that's in another video
but the thyroid can definitely create a
slow
metabolism number five weight gain all
over
the type of fat is not necessarily
adipose tissue it's called mixed edema
so it's a different type of fat which
i'm not going to get into in this video
but it's more like a spongy type
puffy type fat
and number six
tired now if someone's tired that could
be from so many different causes but the
thyroid will definitely make someone
tired as well as depressed okay so
you're going to just feel low you're
going to feel down you're not going to
have that get up and go
unfortunately because everything is
suppressed with the thyroid now the
question is what
can you do about it
here's the plan right here
number one
find out the real cause of the problem
so you're gonna have to do some
investigation yourself
um
the question is do you feel normal when
you're taking these thyroid hormones
like you went to the doctor you're
taking centroid
are are your symptoms normalizing if
they're not then start asking questions
because chances are
it's not the right solution
now if someone tells you well
you know you've been on it for a year
well sometimes it takes several years no
it doesn't if something is going to fix
the problem it's going to fix it
relatively
soon it shouldn't take years and years
and years but
so many people get on these
hormones and they don't really ever get
better
and yes they might be normalizing your
thyroid levels
but
is the thyroid hormones being converted
properly is the problem really in the
blood or is it another location that's
the question
all right b you can do an iodine patch
to see if you really have an iodine
deficiency or not you simply take a
cotton ball and you can get some iodine
from the drugstore like two percent and
then you just apply some iodine to the
inside of your arm or your thigh
and you can cover it up with a little
patch okay and then you basically wait
for 24 hours if within 24 hours okay you
see
no more uh yellow patch then you are
deficient okay
if you still see it completely yellow
chances are you have enough iodine okay
so you can kind of look at it and if
it's fading a little bit maybe you have
a slight deficiency it's not the
perfect test in the world but it can
give you clues on if you're deficient in
iodine another test that you can do for
classic hypothyroidism is the achilles
tendon test you can take a little uh
hammer the one that you would check your
uh reflexes with and just tap the your
achilles tendon or get someone to tap it
now normally what happens if you're
laying down flat and
your foot is hanging down and you tap
this a little achilles tendon here it
should do this right
so what happens with hypothyroidism
is it'll do this but it won't come down
that fast so it's that return
action that's going to be sluggish and
that would be a good test to determine
if you truly have a primary thyroid
problem another important question is
when did it start
was it right after pregnancy which then
can tell you it's an estrogen problem
then you can do with that or was it
after a stress event and then you could
manage your adrenals more with that or
let's say you have a fatty liver well
you might want to then focus on your
liver not the thyroid to get rid of the
primary cause okay
number two the trace minerals are
important not just iodine but selenium
and zinc so take a good trace mineral
product maybe seek help would be good
number three get rid of the gluten in
fact i would get rid of all the grains
that right there
might produce
huge changes and then the vitamin d in
large amounts like 40 000 ius simply
because most thyroid problems are
autoimmune related there's one more
little secret i'm going to tell you it's
called thyrotrophin pmg it's by a
company called standard process
and you have to just seek it out to try
to find it you take one of these before
bed
over a period of three months it seems
to work really good and what happens
when you're taking this this is actually
extract
like an animal extract of the thyroid
okay
and so you're taking this before bed
goes into your stomach
and apparently
it's never been proven but this is the
theory your immune system your
antibodies that are attacking your
thyroid
start attacking that as a decoy
leaving your thyroid alone for a period
of time so your thyroid can kind of come
back it's a really cool strategy that
may potentially
help you
now if you haven't seen my video and how
to do the achilles test i put it up
right here check it out
you